salut à tous c'est pêcheurs de trésors
ça c'est notre aimant surpuissant et
aujourd'hui on va remonter des objets
avec lui dans l'eau
l'important c'est de faire traîner au
maximum les mains et puis de le remonter
dès que vous buter sur quelque chose et
là je crois qu'on a quelque chose de
gros
bisous on est vraiment sur un gros
poisson
mais qui vient tu
vas
ok ça va être très compliqué il y en a
pour quelques minutes là
[Musique]
ok je crois qu'il commence à s'approcher
ouais
regarde moi ce qu'on a sorti de l'eau
super
voilà c'est ça aussi la pêche à l'aimant
et ça c'est signe d'une journée qui
commence très bien là 2007 il est bien
conservé pour en 2007 donc un cadre de
scooter
[Musique]
alors ouais vous avez ici la plaque avec
le numéro de série et ça explique
souvent pourquoi ils finissent dans
l'eau quand ils vole des scooters ils
récupèrent toutes les pièces à part le
cadre et ils ont juste à acheter un
nouveau cadre pour remonter leur nouveau
scooter qui cette fois-ci ne sera pas
déclaré volé quelque chose
ah ouais je crois que c'est un disque
dur
il est mort
alors tu as un gros bout
et c'est de la carrosserie
pas de la carrosserie
c'est un train
qui est suspension
là en face et là-bas d'habitude on crée
un peu quand il s'est vaincu pas la
ferraille mais bon là c'est vrai qu'il y
a le grillage donc c'est pas évident on
vous pardonne pour cette fois
on continue
c'est déjà à bientôt l'été il fait chaud
qui est en train de venir pour moi ça
réagit un petit peu comme le cadre de
scooter de tout à l'heure là il a lâché
mais il faut savoir que c'est souvent le
cas on arrive à les faire avancer petit
à petit et il faut relancer tout le
rattraper voilà si c'est un cadre de
scooter typiquement il faut réussir à
coincer les mains entre plusieurs
parties du cadre au segment quand même
fort
je pense qu'effectivement ça va être un
cas mais
c'est
ouais ouais c'est pas d'un cadre c'est
des morceaux de carrosserie découpée
un peu là
c'est pas si long
il y a une plaque
ok c'est un morceau de toi oui oui c'est
à toi
on dirait une française d'après moi
[Musique]
ok oui on voit quand même que les mecs
maîtrisent le geste regarde comme
ça comment ils sont habitués surtout là
aussi des pros des vrais pro
c'est marrant parce qu'à chaque fois
qu'on s'arrête on trouve un morceau puis
plus rien bon on va continuer à avancer
on va se retrouver
oh oui oui oui munition
je crois que c'est toi aussi
en vrai elle est pas très vieille
pour moi il est vers là
ouais mais moi j'ai eu ici moi je tirais
bon on a remonté en même temps au début
de 38 spéciale donc là pas le choix faut
trouver soit d'autres munitions soit le
gun
ça rafraîchit allez voyons voir on l'a
bien fait traîner oui j'en vois déjà une
deux
d'un coup
38 spécial elles sont récentes
je garde et on va refaire le même lancer
exactement
peut-être
toi aussi une
c'est bon
[Musique]
tu avais tiré vers moi carrément là ou
plus là-bas
on va regarder ça
oui une
est-ce qu'on va le trouver
je sais pas quels étaient montées
spéciales
ouais deux
il y en a un
ok du cuivre
et encore une
de maison de la détection ils rigolent
pas quand vous avez des boulons comme ça
allez on évacuera ça après hop
en général les 38 spécial c'est des
revolver c'est des grosses
ça pourrait être très très drôle d'en
trouver un très très drôle
une pile des pollution et du coup
j'ai tellement cru
un bout de pot d'échappement je suis
encore une fois le poids c'est pas mal
on est à combien 12
de blague
de temps en temps
de viande qui est remonté Baptiste et un
morceau de viande qui remonté quand j'ai
acheté les mains
ça ça pue ça regardez
ça arrive assez souvent de trouver de la
viande dans les canaux notamment pour
les personnes qui apattent le silure
mais ici la forme est un petit peu
spéciale on n'a pas vraiment réussi à
l'identifier mais si c'est votre domaine
de compétence et que vous pensez
reconnaître un bout de viande qui ne
devrait pas être dans l'eau n'hésitez
pas à nous envoyer un message alors
qu'est-ce qu'on a de beau
forcément morceau de carrosserie
tu as quelque chose on est une partie je
pense
[Musique]
parce qu'on en a marre avec les mains
c'est super lourd
voilà c'était un toit
bon décidément même avec un grappin ça
ne suffit pas cet objet là va rester là
pour l'instant et on reviendra essayer
de le pêcher une autre fois pendant ce
temps est en face et récupère la
ferraille qui avait été abandonné par
d'autres pêcheurs on a quand même fait
une belle sortie même si on n'a pas
trouvé de dingues aujourd'hui à part les
munitions c'est quand même très bien
d'avoir trouvé ces munitions là c'est
sûr que le revolver a été dans l'eau où
est encore dans l'eau mais la chance n'a
pas été de notre côté cette fois-ci on
se retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle
vidéo de pêche à la main